hello everyone my name is Eric Williams
and I'm a staff scientist in our cell
biology are in the group at Thermo
Fisher Scientific today I'll share some
of the improvements that we've made in
building IPSC derived disease models
you
everyone knows that ever since Yamanaka
came up with the reprogramming of
somatic cells that these models have
taken off in the field and now allow us
to generate any kind of differentiated
cell type from a diseased patient
through reprogramming after having the
differentiated cell types we can then
look for disease phenotypes in a dish
and then ultimately put those cells in a
screening assay to discover drugs for
treating the patient's disease so really
building a cell model is very useful to
predict inputs and outputs from a
particular disease and hopefully in the
long term these sort of assays can then
be used to translate treatment in
organisms such as humans so thermo
Fisher over the years has put together a
wide portfolio of tools workflows and
services to address the IPSC disease
modeling field so we have a lot of tools
in terms of characterizing patient
samples such as our next-generation
sequencing equipment we have our
reprogramming kits such as site attune
where you can now take a somatic cell
from a patient and reprogram goes into
pluripotent stem cells you can then
culture those reproduce themselves in a
variety of media that we have as well as
a number of matrices we have reagents
and analysis tools to characterize your
stem cells we then have genome editing
tools so you can engineer genome of
those cells and furthermore we have
differentiation reagents where you can
then start turning your pluripotent stem
cells into your cell type of interest
which they can which can then be used to
run biochemical and Teller assays using
one of our instruments or reagents so we
really have a wide variety of tools that
can be used in a pluripotent stem cell
workflow
furthermore the majority of the tools
that we have are also being implemented
in services that we run internally for
any customer academic biotech Pharma
so today my presentation is going to
focus on the new innovations we have
around genome editing in pluripotent
stem cells to generate
isogenic disease models so typically
when you're talking about isogenic
disease model zero is thinking about
comparing a healthy donor with a patient
donor however there's a high variability
between different patients so with
genome editing we can actually get
around that now so for example we could
take a healthy donor derive it IPS ES
and we could then use genome editing to
introduce particular mutations to then
mimic a diseased donor sample and in the
opposite direction we could take a
patient sample drive the FPSes again and
then do a genome edit to correct those
diseased relative mutations so that you
now have a matched isogenic Bart pair
coming from the same donor
so about five years ago after ma Fisher
we started a collaboration with the
Parkinson's Institute to try and do
exactly that so we had a number of
patient fibroblasts with that were
carrying mutations relevant to
Parkinson's disease and we then wanted
to try and reverse some of these
mutations using genome editing tools
that were available at that time
and then further differentiate
yourselves into neurons and look at some
phenotypic differences between the
disease sample and the genome edited
control so we took those patient
fibroblasts we used our site attune
reprogramming kids to turn those
fibroblasts into induced pluripotent
stem cells we then glue those
pluripotent stem cells using our
essential aid medium and fit Renekton
matrix which were top-of-the-line at
that time and we then used our towel
based genome editing system to deliver
snipped Corrections into the genome of
these cells
we danced further differentiated them
using our neural stem cells and did some
some relevant assays and while in the
long run we were successful in doing
this it took us about a year and a half
to go from a patient fibroblasts to
successfully edited pluripotent stem
cell so we identified some clear
bottlenecks including the design of the
genome editing tools themselves so the
talents that we have back then were DNA
based and also for introducing the snips
we required a larger donor and using
those two DNA based methods typically
yielded very low editing efficiency both
at the level of in delft formation as
well as homology driven repair and then
secondly for DNA delivery
there are several caveats in the plur
button stem cell field as well first of
all the two based methods are not very
efficient electroporation was the only
option but electroporation is somewhat
stressful to stem cells and a
furthermore delivery of DNA causes
adverse effects such as spontaneous
differentiation or even genomic
instability in some cases
so the tools and the delivery was a big
problem and was not setting us up for
success downstream in terms of isolating
clones but the isolation of clones
itself is a challenge as well so back
then media systems did not really
support single cell sorting so we were
forced to do manual approaches where we
would manually isolate clones by cutting
them into pieces and expanding one piece
for during culture and using the other
piece for you know genomic DNA analysis
but then because of that manual picking
clones were often found to be mixed
populations and due to the fact that
these populations were make TaqMan qpcr
asses or Sanger sequencing acids were
always difficult to interpret interpret
because there were those different cell
types in that clone so really the pain
in the whole genome editing process was
on the one hand was the delivery of the
tools and the tool itself but at the
same time the clonal isolation and
screening had an equal problem in the
whole workflow which made it a laborious
and iterative process where you have to
go back several times to get to a
success
so in the past couple years thermo
Fisher has worked on a number of
innovations to improve that genome
editing to helping the IPC is these
model construction that the level of
genome editing tools we developed a
cassadine protein called through cut
cast knife which works very well for
genome editing in pure potent stem cells
in addition we release perfect match
towels which are an RNA based tile
method which is easier to deliver than
DNA to the IPS see and then third we
also have a cast nine IPSC line which is
a IPSC liner has a stable expressing
cast nine protein and I'll come back to
these different tools in a minute and
then we also have delivery tools we have
our neon electroporator and then we also
have a life affection based system like
effect means them that would help in
delivering the various editing tools and
then for clonal isolation one of our
biggest innovations there's our stem
flex medium which is a medium that was
designed to promote single cell survival
of IPS ES and that has now allowed us to
do single cell sorting using facts of
ipsps
to reliably isolate single cell clones
and then third as I mentioned previously
we have a number of kits and reagents
that allow you to look at your disease
model and analyze possible phenotypes so
we have differentiation kids for
cardiomyocytes dopaminergic neurons and
other CNS neurons and then we have a
large variety of assays including cell
health assays other cell based assays
and we also have high content imaging
instruments and so on
so right now we'll just deep dive a
little bit in some of these technologies
and kind of show you what we what we
achieved with those new tools so the
first new tool is our table
cast iron IPSC line so what we did is we
took that IPSC line and try to introduce
a number of snips as well as just doing
in the introduction by just introducing
the guide and so what we've used on the
one hand was a genomic cleavage athlete
to just look at the endo formation and
an example of genomically which assays
are shown on the top in that DNA gel on
the other hand we looked at snip
introduction efficiency using targeted
next-generation sequencing and on the
right hand slide on the right hand side
of the slide you have an example of what
a next-generation sequencing result
looks like so you can clearly see
between a wild-type
and a sample that has some snips that we
can clearly detect the presence of snips
on a number of alleles
so when you look at that from a broader
picture over nine targets that we looked
at here for all of those targets we
typically get about 20 to 80 percent in
the introduction efficiency and as you
can appreciate that number is highly
target dependent and furthermore when we
look at snips we typically get somewhere
between five and forty percent homology
driven repair so the cast nine IPSC line
is really an efficient tool to introduce
a high number of mutations using one
donor background
however we understand that sometimes you
want to do editing in your own IPSC or
in a specific patient right IPSC to the
tools that we derive there was our true
cut cast 9 protein so it's a protein
that then complements with a guide RNA
and that guide RNA protein complex can
then be delivered to the cells so on the
left hand side you see the efficiency of
snip introduction on three different
targets and using three of the tools
that we've had in our catalog and you
can see that the stable cast 9 as I've
shown in a previous slide performs
really well and then our first
generation cast 9 protein did not do so
well in pluripotent stem cells but then
our second generation through cut cast 9
protein works very well and matches the
efficiency of the gasps knife stable
line so genome editing in your own IP se
line now becomes much easier and in the
left hand side everything was delivered
using our neon electroporator but we
understand that an eon electroporator is
not always available to you
so we then also developed a like
perfection based reagent called by
perfecto means stem and when we compare
these 5 different conditions here
looking at different genomic targets in
two different IPS sea lines what you can
generally appreciate it that the neon is
really the better system to achieve
efficient genome editing but at the same
time like effect amines them allows you
for three of those four targets or 33 of
those five targets you can still get
fairly efficient genome editing to the
extent that you can still successfully
isolate clones
which then brings me to the innovations
that we've done around the single cell
clonal isolation of to reportin stem
cells after doing the genome editing so
you always want to isolate a single cell
clone after the genome editing just so
that you can have homogeneous cell lines
either being a homozygous edit or a
heterozygous edit so we spent quite a
bit of time and trying to optimize
single cell sorting on their potent stem
cells to get to a reliable single cell
isolation within the field of two 93,000
cancer cell lines using packs for single
cell isolation is very common so we
really try to achieve the same with
pluripotent stem cells so we first set
up a very stringent gating strategy
where we looked at different forward and
side scatter gates to remove debris and
doublet and then we furthermore
introduced a double gating strategy
using propidium iodide and tri 160
antibodies to be able to reliably sort
viable pluripotent stem cells and after
we had set that up we then looked into
different soft substrates different cell
media and different supplements to try
and see whether any of the posts or
conditions could help in promoting
survival of pluripotent stem cells after
the cell going through a cell sorter
which is typically a stressful event and
in a nutshell what we observed was that
under standard conditions and now I'm
looking at the histogram plot on the
left that the standard media conditions
such as essential aid and gel tricks
didn't really reliably yield any single
cell clone however when we started
adding our vitamins provided self
supplements as well as laminate five to
one we noticed that we could lightly
increase the efficiency to ten to
fifteen percent of single cell survival
however when we introduced our new stem
flex medium into the system we were all
of a sudden getting clone survival
indeed thirty to fifty percent range
which is really a dramatic increase in
the efficiency and as you can see on the
images in the right hand side the single
cell clones have a normal or potent
morphology and are staining really
nicely for her potent markers so really
by using the fact system we were able to
bring down the clonal isolation from a
several month process with having to
actually manual clone several times to
get to your clone online we now brought
that down into a process that takes
about two weeks
which is a dramatic improvement so we
then use this single cell sorting method
on some of the disease snip pool that we
had made in a stable cast nine line and
we isolated somewhere between 200 and
300 clones and then stream those clones
by sequencing to understand what
distribution was of the different
heterozygous homozygous unedited or
random endo
clones in in that collection of pool
so as you can appreciate from the five
star gets shown here when when we do the
editing under the colonial isolation you
will typically with different degrees of
success you will typically identify a
homozygous nib using using the editing
methods I have described however you'll
appreciate that heterozygous snips shown
in blue are not always found and then in
opals evidently we are defecting in
Delft still where the homology driven
repair did not occur and then there's
also a number of unedited those in those
clones and there is some correlation
between the overall editing efficiency
at a particular target and and the total
success of in doubt and/or homologies
even right there
so that with this I'm going to switch to
one of these these models and kind of
present you a little case study that
we've done in in the development of a
model for Parkinson's disease so what we
did is we introduced the Lark to g20
19's mutation using the tools that have
described in our cash nine IPSC line we
then use our stem flex medium with lemon
and five to one and revise itself to
isolate the single cell clones and we
then took those edit itself and put them
through our differentiation kids for
dopaminergic neurons and then we ran
some assays to see whether we could
reveal any functional phenotypes that
are known to be associated with the lark
to mutation so before I go into the
actual differentiation and assays just
really want to highlight the importance
of characterizing your additive stem
cells after during the genome editing
because both the genome editing in a
single cell sorting are stressful events
to the cell and so we did a number of
characterization assays to make sure
that the pluripotent stem cell lines
that we had derived carrying limitation
were normal IPS es so the first asset
that we looked at is our sacrament PCR
based scorecard assay so it basically
assesses the pluripotency
of the cells and as you can see in
between the red and the black dots there
is virtually no difference between the
two showing that the edited IPS C is not
different from a unedited IPS see at the
level of lower potency and then this was
also further confirmed in our
high-resolution pleurotus assay which is
a whole genome microarray based platform
that assesses the reportin see
we then evidently also looked at the
sequence both at the level of Sanger
sequencing to make sure that the Edit in
our final pool was still there and at
the same time we also looked at the
sequence using next-generation
sequencing so that we could look at
10,000 products of the different alleles
represented in the cell line to make
sure that the line was clonal and then
lastly we looked at our carrier cell
assay which is a digital karyotyping
assay to make sure that there was no
genomic instability that occurred during
the editing and/or clonal isolation by a
fax process but in general what we
observed is that color potency and the
karyotype were unaffected by the genome
editing or single cell sorting and we
found that the genome added maintained
was maintained in the genome and that
the line was indeed clone after one run
of single cell sorting so now we know
that we knew that we then moved on to
differentiating these IPS ease into
dopaminergic neurons and here is some
example immunostaining of cultures
containing dopaminergic neurons both for
the Caston and wild-type IPS see line as
well as they cast nine IPS sea-based
mutant on the top and what you can see
is there's clear expression of T H which
is a dopaminergic specific marker as
well as beta tubulin which is a more
general neuronal marker so we then took
tusk neurons
replaced them and then tracked the
outgrowth of neurons over time so the
graph on the left hand side is basically
showing you the neurite lengths per cell
over time and what you can see in the
early outgrowth of the neurons which is
indicated by the red circle and line and
directs you to the top graph you can see
that the lar to G 20:19 s outgrowth of
neurons is delayed compared to a
cassadine control and even some of the
other dopaminergic disease mutants that
we've looked at
and if you now wait until neurites have
outgrown fully and sort of stabilized in
terms of length we then or even able to
distinguish in different phenotypes who
are refund that the lack to mutant had
overall longer no rights whereas the SNC
a mutant that we've also worked at has
shortened arise we then also looked at
the festivity to six hydroxy dopa which
is a very well established phenotype for
dopaminergic neurons related to
Parkinson's disease and using a
apoptosis assay which is our sullivan
caspase-3 7si we then try to understand
whether this is indeed the case with
their disease model so the way the faa
works is that
in a normal condition you basically you
would have no cafes exposed or not much
cafes as exposed as you can see under
DMSO condition the majority of the cells
are blue however when you introduce a
cytotoxic reagent like star aspirin you
get all the cafe's exposed which can
then be detected resulting in a green
signal so is clearly see between the
DMSO and sparrow you see a clear
increase in the green signal and
similarly with hydroxy dopa we see the
same effect when you now quantify that
in a normal media condition where
glucose is present you can clearly see
that the number of apoptotic cells is
highly increased in the lark to g20 19's
mutation however when you now stress the
cells a little bit more by removing the
glucose you see that the alert to g21
19's mutant still has higher levels of
apoptosis compared to control but now
the other SNC a Parkinson's mutant shows
the same phenotype so there's a clear
clear correlation between big hydroxido
past activity and the presence of
Parkinson's related mutations
we furthermore looked into some gene
expression profiling where we looked at
genes that are uniquely associated with
lark to mutant so in the plot on the
left hand side you see a panel of genes
that are known to be upregulated in
patients with large to g20 19's
mutations and as you can see across the
board they are overexpressed in our
system compare and control with the
large two mutant and what's even more
interesting is that these genes are not
up regulated in our SSC a mutant so this
clearly indicates that this gene
expression that we're observing in the
lab two mutant is specifically related
to the alert two mutants
so with that I'm going to end and
summarize what I've covered so as I've
shown you we have a number of new genome
editing tools coolant isolation tools
and disease model generation tools that
allow you to reliably generate a disease
model and then study the phenotypes in
an in vitro setting and with those new
tools for genome editing we now support
higher cleavage efficiency and homology
driven repair and these tools also
generate less stress on the cells and so
this spontaneous differentiation and
genomic stability is not affected as
much we then have new tools for the
kernel isolation where you can now
single arise and single cells or
pluripotent stem cells or coolant
isolation is no longer a bottleneck in
the genome editing workflow and
heterogeneous populations are rarely
found since pack sorting is a highly
highly reliable method and one round is
sufficient to isolate full Econoline and
then I've shown you that using our
differentiation kids you can then show
that these genome edited models can be
differentiated into a relevant cell type
and you can then run a number of assays
and really what these tools now allow
you to do is to really make a disease
model much faster with less hands on
time so we're talking about going from a
process that took about a year and a
half with a lot of hands-on time to a
process that now takes four to six
months with a lot less than sometimes
so with that I would like to thank you
for your attention and if you have any
questions please submit the questions
and we will respond to those questions
by email thank you